hello everybody welcome to the
fourth bitcoin trading video in this
video what we're gonna be looking at
is our historical data uh basically we
just wanna use like a super basic
graph so it's not gonna be pretty like
this one if you think this one is pretty
that is
uh because our main goal with this is
just to kind of visualize the data
so we can use it sort of like it's
debugging and also so we know we're on
the right track so we're actually doing
what we're expecting
uh ourselves to be doing right so the
first thing we want to do is actually
take a peek
at this data so uh i've got an empty
script here so we're going to be coding
in here
wherever you've downloaded that file
just put in the same
folder directory uh whatever you want to
call it as this
script or give the full path to it
wherever you've saved it
so with that let's go ahead and get
started and check out our data so
what we want to do is we want to import
time just in case we want to add a
sleeper uh for debugging purposes
uh you we might not need that at all but
just put it there anyways
import date time uh we'll just leave
this here because if we ever want to
actually plot it up and have
uh date stamps we want to have date time
there uh
then we're going to import numpy as mp
um then we're going to want uh import
matplotlib
and then finally import matplotlib dot
pi plot as plt
um you can also just comma separate all
this
a lot of this stuff anyways but uh i
like to separate them out
so now what we want to do is we want we
just need like a little simple function
uh to um graph up this data so i'm just
going to come down here and i'm going to
say define
testing data and in here we're going to
have
btc date r
for data array then we're going to have
btc price
r for the prices array and then btc
volume r uh for the volume right now you
don't have to have volume i
will we'll still cut we might look at it
every now and then to compare because
volume is a good way to measure uh
trend consistency or trend strength
rather so
as long as the trend is moving and the
volume is either staying stable or
increasing you can
relatively uh calculate the fat
calculate it so to think that that trend
will continue it's only when volume
starts to change or trend even starts to
change
while volume doesn't change that you
would say oh the velocity is going down
and all that but
more on that way later probably so
anyway so what we want to do now is have
a try
and then we'll have an accept exception
e and then we'll print um
failed uh
raw data and then we'll have string e
just in case we do fail
and then within the try what we're going
to have is source code is going to equal
open and we want to open up that file we
downloaded so it's btc usd
dot csv with the intention to read it
and then we'll go ahead and actually
read that data
then we're going to want to say split
source and that's going to equal
source code dot split and we want to
split that by a new line
then we'll come down a little bit and
let me make some space so
coding kind of in the middle here uh and
we're going to say for
each line in split source what do we
actually want to do here well
split line is going to equal
each line.split and we want to split it
by a
comma because the variables in that file
are comma separated variables let me
bring it up
actually to show you guys so i do want
to mention one more thing too about this
data
is uh so this is what the data looks
like and
from the actual apis themselves the data
looks
a lot different like this isn't the way
that the apis are going to look
but at least on this website where we've
downloaded this data
every exchange data format so i've seen
so far anyways
looks just like this so it's a unix
timestamp uh the price
and the volume so obviously you can see
here with btce
they didn't even start tracking at their
earliest prices at 11
where if you look at mount gox i think
they go back all the way to like a
dollar or something in fact
let's uh let's go ahead and bring up
mount gox let's click on that real quick
right so this is kind of why there's
probably mount gox is larger than btce
even though i'm
i'm relatively certain that there this
this website is probably pulling from
the api and btce's
much uh higher granularity anyway
as you can see here the price of these
bitcoins is like
five pennies right starting at mount gox
so mount gox was kind of like one of the
first exchanges right i think it
probably
came before btce and then it starts
going up but as you can see before we
even get to
the 11 mark we've gone through wow okay
wait
slow down hold your horses like right
about here
right we've got three million rows
already so keep that in mind and
the total amount of rows we had three
million by then
and the the total amount of rows is only
uh seven million
so that'll give you kind of an idea of
how much higher granularity
btce has because they have um
5.6 and they started 3 million rows
later and
all that but anyway this is what the
data looks like uh that's what i was
that's all i meant to say is what the
data looks like and i got
caught up in that anyway so it's it's
comma separated
hence the csv name and it's btc uh we're
going to
say bbc date equals split line
and then that zeroth element right
that's the unix stamp um
btc price equals split line and that was
the second part right so the first fifth
element
and then btc volume equals
uh split line two
now let's check for typos because we no
doubt
i don't see them but we'll have one i'm
sure btc
uh date r a dot
append and we want to append uh the
float
of btc date then we want to do
the next here i'm not sure what happened
there
anyway uh btc price array dot append
um in fact let me move this thing out of
the way
it might just be getting angry at me
since it's refreshing a lot
uh anyway btc price array.append
uh we want to append the float b
dc price and then finally btc
volume array dot append
uh flow btc
volume okay
now what we want to do is we're pretty
much done there because we've now
filled up all of the information itself
now i want to come down here and um
we really just at this point we can
start plotting all this stuff i'm trying
to think of when i wanted to cut
um some stuff off of here because
there's gonna be so much data
that's coming through here so like right
here it might make sense like
we can add a variable up here and call
it how far
back equals and for the purposes here
let's say 50
000 and then instead of like reading
every line in the split source because
there is again like what
five million lines if we try to plot
five million lines it would take
like 10 minutes for this graph to show
up uh
so minus how far
back colon um it's not only plot 50
000 lines so it should pop up pretty
quick for us now
we could also use my granularity if you
followed my granularity tutorial uh you
could do the same thing there like once
you've populated all these
uh cut the granularity however much you
want and then you would get you know
the full historical graph because really
like this will cut off a lot of the
stuff behind but again
we're mostly using this so we can test
the logic
later on so anyway coming down here what
we're going to say is
plt.plot btc
date array so all the dates and then btc
price array now of course this is going
to plot in unix time
right and you could of course fix that
as well if you wanted to
but again we don't really care if it's
not the most pretty graph in the world
and then finally we can do plot.show and
that should show the plot
now let me clear off some of this space
and then let's actually call
uh this function here so come down paste
and let's see our data if we had any
errors nope we didn't
should plot or it should pop up pretty
quick for you guys so here
is uh the data right so now we can
actually see it again
uh the timestamp is quite ugly of course
but we're just
trying to look at it visually this looks
to be about right we've got the right
prices here and it has been going up and
then
it's kind of started to go down today um
so everything looks good now we're ready
to progress into the next
uh part so uh as always thanks for
watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and thank you for your
bitcoin
donations bye
you